as we all know the holidays are a time
of giving so we thought it would be
appropriately festive to look back at
the times when gifts were given in
eSports but we're not talking about any
regular old skin or loot box we're
talking about the gift of pills or games
or really anything that qualifies is
what people would usually refer to as
throws oh oh that is heartbreaking today
we wanted to highlight all of the failed
death brushes and crushing reverse
sweeps the things that left us wondering
what in God's name did we just witness
so cozy up to the fire and start running
that comment about how cévennes Azrael
is totally gonna be on this list
because today we're counting down the
top ten throws in eSports now you may be
surprised to see our list starting off
with a throw from one of counterstrikes
greatest players but here we are at map
point vs. Team Liquid and ESL one
cologne 2019 s group stage simple
managed to get the jump on nitro to win
the map but being the showman that he is
simple decided against safely sniping
nitro and instead opted for the BM knife
kill Matt point looking to be confirmed
[Music]
simple of course try to push it through
and it's in close out a game don't know
if anyone please it's for money
essentially do not do it to showboat it
doesn't matter you might have just cost
him the game there that was one of the
silliest plays I've seen in a long time
simples throw served as the catalyst for
TLS comeback as the North American team
went on to win both the map and the
match thanks to that blunder they had to
game in the palm of the hand and they
threw in the trash
in a three-on-one Golan neither tender
mappoint has cost him their map pic and
a pastor three is number one in the
world what's worse than messing up a
combo and Street Fighter 5 well messing
up a combo with a hundred and ten
thousand dollars on the line don't
believe us we'll just ask phenom who
experienced just that during Ealy Street
Fighter 5 invitationals Grand Finals on
the verge of defeat phenom found the
combo he needed to tie up the series
then this happened
[Applause]
it's one thing to throw around for the
sake of BM but to with all your shots at
an open target in front of thousands at
IEM Gamescom well that brings a whole
different level of embarrassment to it
poor Kari can just wanted to end the
round with some flair but instead
through it by missing just about every
pistol shot talk about putting an F in
chat care just got charged him down
is it miss quite a few pistol shots
Kenny yes II wanna kill the round oh my
lord that should not happen coming in at
number 7 is a truly heartbreaking throw
courtesy of Evil Geniuses at the Rainbow
six pro league season 9 finals in fact
this throw was so bad that we made an
entire video about it here's what you
need to know one point away from beating
favorites team Empire it looked like eg
had this win in the bag but Canadian got
a bit too overzealous and attempted a
super risky kill that didn't go as
planned
unfortunately that decision was the
beginning of the end for the boys in
blue comes the tension here comes the
push down on white stairs waiting for
the vault on in is Canadian will he be
able to secure the kill he sees the
tracers don't know Scyther will win the
fight he'll inch his way on up Chios
gonna be next in line but this could be
a tough shot an empire could wrestle
away the round
there's Gio just waiting he doesn't pull
the trigger he sees it he pops up
oh no Gio you gotta hit your shots young
will be the last one left he was so
important for faze he turns his back
he's got the pistol but Sheppard will
deny the
back from EG on that round and the hopes
and dreams will wave one more round at
minimum will we have overtime between
these two teams
not only the ichi going to lose that map
but they also lost the following map
throwing what was supposed to be their
tournament to win in the process
EG inches away but they fumble number
six on our list is to throw the TSM fans
know all too well
so we're sorry for bringing you back up
oh god please no no well on their way to
dethrone aback to back LCS champions
Team Liquid all the TSM's ven needed to
do was play safe guess what happened
next though find that opening so far TSM
has outmaneuvered Aaron in a play that
we are still trying to figure out the
all-star ad carry ran straight into team
liquids warm embrace like what are we
doing what is the objective that we have
fighting for hey did he die try to get
the [ __ ] spire control why
exercise bought lane what are we doing
thanks to Sven's gift teamliquid made
their comeback one of the game and
earned their third consecutive domestic
title that first pull onto Sven that's
what set all of this back in the motion
number five in our list is a legendary
throw from Evo 2015's guilty gear
tournaments to refresh your memory
washing a thought he'd won the match
after landing a sick combo for the ko
but boy was he in for a nasty surprise
so smart he couldn't burst because of
the super his opponent Ogawa's Otto
showed no mercy to a showboating will
she get taking the set before his
opponent even returned
oh my god and that kids is why you
always make sure that the game is over
before celebrating your win for a number
four entry we're bringing you a throw
that happened all the way back during
ti3 at match point against Navi Orange
eSports earned a huge advantage by
taking down Roshan well that is to say
they would have had a huge advantage you
had K Y X Y not accidentally denied the
agents and then just deal with this agus
when it comes out should be on the hands
of bushy and back to his hands of
Windrunner yeah then I want to deny that
they failed all the ages tonight PI K Y
X Y I think we just saw right here and
that's like $10,000 and a spot in the
grand final on the line and then that
happens with the ages out of orange
esports his hands Navi clawed their way
back into the game and the rest as they
say is history
[Applause]
International grand final one game away
from becoming smash Ultimates inaugural
Evo champion it looks like tweak was
finally about to take the mantle of
Ultimates best player away from MK leo
the tournament was tweaks to lose MK Leo
needed to do the impossible and win six
rounds in a row if he wanted to win and
if you haven't guessed it by now he did
just that
hail to the king baby survived taking
him out of it going up - oh sweet men if
you're in the scenario you gotta feel
kind of bad about it Jimmy spiked it he
missed a layup be quick to be your 2019
Evo champion tweaks Grand Finals to feed
will forever go down as one of the worst
throws and Evo history there is no more
embarrassing feeling and overwatch than
throwing a map because your team forgot
to hop on the objective a mistake that
is now commonly referred to by fans as
the c9 so how did sinon get associated
with such a boneheaded move well back in
the day of oceans apex tournament the
old c9 lineup made this mistake not once
it does get the one under dong-hyun
going on to that and it looks like a
freak of blue did they just not touch
the point I guess not not twice and oh
trying to run away nobodies are you
hitting me again
what yeah two rounds in a row that
cloud9
could have easily contested that and no
one was on the point but three times in
a row
oh the overtime nobody was able to stay
on the point well that's just a
heartbreak see nines legendary
performance in 2017 started a meme that
will forever live on in the overwatch
community oh my god that was actually a
scene oh my god all right well what does
c9 means is when you step off of an
objective when a teamfight is still in
progress or won and that actually
happened taking the top spot on our list
is none other than the LPL's infamous
Oscar night in fact we did a whole video
on this display of mediocrity but for
those who don't know about it here's the
skinny back in the final week of the LPL
2015 spring split LGD gaming and
Invictus gaming faced off in a match
that would determine their playoff
seedings considering that the winner of
that game would move into a bracket with
favorites Edward gaming both teams did
everything they could to well lose Oh
Sampat fate to come through just to make
sure kid is gonna be locked in position
for a while that is not a good idea as
got B's now disabled to destroy him from
a G's trolli champ select I wonder which
patch save thinks he's on because of
course save hasn't played for a while
the mind may wander yes play competitive
for a while I'm sure he's played League
of Legends quite recently it's not about
that Eve but is what we have at listen
if you get to this game my goodness to
lgd's fake acting in front of the camera
Oscar night in the LPL earned its spot
as the greatest throw in eSports history
if with a massive flip into the bottom
line that's the tempered fate kid still
going to die that's centered around now
say he lives no he doesn't he decides to
walk back around again and I have no
idea what's going on this game
see I told you cévennes Ezreal is gonna
be on this list be sure to throw us a
like a subscribe and let us know in the
comments if you think there's any
heartbreaking moments that we left out
see you next time well I hole we threw a
bat clash throw I'm Saturday was really
bad really bad no I think it was kind of
equally all of our fault we dove Tier
three we were up to in Hibbs had baron
we threw really really hard that was
insane throw that could be on this list
they were so bad